And over buddy, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters who are talking about what we do with Lyme disease autoimmune disease vaccine injury and such.
Anything other than cancer in this clinic is on this website right here that you're on the my hope for Lyme though it's more inclusive than Lyme it's that's our base website.
You're watching this video because you're interested at least in what we do and what we offer here.
And I recommend you explore our site that's the key component we could have spent a lot of money doing a fancy video and paying a company to do a video but would rather put our money in adding information on our site.
Gathering as much information and offering as much free information that's part of our ministry here and you're going to see as we explore these options that you have with our clinic that that's really where our heart is.
When you look at our website you'll see our clinic you can click on that tab and see who we are and get some faces that go with the voices if you communicate with us.
And then our protocols are self directed care is our key and that links back to our classroom in our classroom we are going to be constantly updating and adding information so that you can choose to try to take care of yourself.
And we fully realize in taking care of Lyme and autoimmune and cancer patients over the last 30 years that a lot of people with chronic disease are financially tapped and they are struggling to try to find Lyme literate doctors that will care for them that they can afford to go to.
That's what the purpose of this entire website is yes we do have a nutritionally guided plan and a full right plan that people can choose to utilize and utilize our services but our classroom with all the information all the books that we give free of charge is really for your benefit.
The classroom has information on Lyme disease genetics of vaccine injuries autoimmune detoxification and this will be added to so by the time this video is out after a period of time there will be more tabs in the classroom as well.
Please look at those things and follow our blogs these are some of the faces that you'll see this is Diane and Angie if you do communicate with our clinic we have other employees as well.
Everybody if you do decide to get clinic directed care start with a case review a case review is communication with myself or one of the practitioners about 30 minutes when we go over history and what's going on currently and decide you know what would be a good fit for you is it to just follow self directed care and use our classroom is it to utilize our nutritionally guided plan or our full right plan.
Part of that has to do with your finances part of that has to do with your current set of knowledge and what you want to do so we're not here to try to sell anything or push anything out here we're trying to give you the best offerings that are best for you.
That's the whole idea we want you to choose what's best for you and give you those options so that you can take care of yourself.
If you are catching this video on YouTube go to my hope for lime dot com you'll see all our information this is a screenshot of our begin here page is that's where you'll start makes sense right begin here start with a case review you can look at all of our information for free we're always adding to our blogs and videos and store so look at that information I hope this helps blessings.
Dr. Connors.